so much has been written about The
Sopranos what in your mind is The
Sopranos about
the reason of Sopranos
successful is and I've said this before
is it deals with children it deals with
parents it deals with family I mean I
think the the older characters and The
Sopranos especially in the beginning you
don't see older characters written like
that then I mean you know you have to
put certain things to to escalate it a
little bit and that's the mafia part of
it but in a way that's about family
family too you know loyalty and you know
big issues like that and I just think
it's it's so well written I mean the
writers
I will you know I don't think I've ever
said this to most of the writes because
I basically like to have a slightly
adversarial is that the word the
relationship with them but I think
they're unbelievable I mean I sit there
and read it and just go Jesus Christ
it's so goddamn smart